We've heard
a lot of different facts
about how Puerto Rico is faring
in the wake of Hurricane Maria.
And while President Trump
says Puerto Rico is doing great,
I only believe what I can see
with my own eyes
and touch with my own
no-problem-down-there-sized
hands.
That's why I flew down
to Puerto Rico
to find out the truth about
Trump's recovery efforts myself.
Take a look.
I've watched Puerto Rico
face an unprecedented amount
of damage after Hurricane Maria.
But I was impressed
by President Trump
when he swung in,
paper towels in hand,
and he cleaned up that mess
to his own rave reviews.
We have done an incredible job.
What is your death count
as of this moment, 17?
-16 certified.
-16 people.
I give ourselves a ten.
A ten. A ten.
So I headed down
to gather thank yous
and see Donald Trump's
perfect score firsthand.
Puerto Rico!
Ten out of ten?
Ten out of ten.
Ten.
The cables are more of a six.
Probably, like, a three.
Jesus.
I don't even know what that is.
That's...
that's probably, like, a two.
Okay, so if I'm keeping score,
we're probably averaging out
to about a 6.5.
But if you round up,
that's a ten, baby.
And in the neighborhoods
of San Juan,
people are even back to work,
specifically kids.
These kids organized
getting generators
for this community center so it
has power to teach other kids.
Did it all by themselves.
Didn't need adults' help.
Probably should offer my help.
I should...
They got it now anyway.
These kids were working hard
but not in school,
because, technically, only 40%
of the schools are open
and 60% of people
have no power.
Half a million people
are without clean water.
But, still, I could tell
this was a good news story.
Right,
DHS Secretary Elaine Duke?
I know it-it is really
a good news story
in terms of our ability
to-to reach people
and the limited number of deaths
that have taken place.
"Limited number"-- that makes
it almost sound special.
But some people had
their own narrative.
Damn it,
this is not a good news story.
Unbelievable. Mayor Cruz
should be saying thank you,
but, instead,
she's on the warpath.
I want to confront Mayor Cruz
to talk to her
about some of the language
she's using
to communicate with
our president, Donald Trump.
This is a ten out of 100,
which is still a failing grade.
There's no power,
no communications,
no phones, and no electricity.
Is that a ten out of a ten?
It's tough for America
to get supplies here.
You can't drive a truck here. I
don't know if you realize that.
That's right, 'cause we are
an island surrounded by water.
-Lots and lots of water. Ocean
water, right? -Exactly. Exactly.
We didn't know that
until this happened.
Well, that's what I'm saying.
It's-it's difficult.
Don't you think you need
to give us a little leeway?
The most powerful country
in the world
can't get their logistics
together?
-I don't think so.
-I saw pictures.
You're out having fun swimming,
and he's out there making deals
on a golf course.
When you're playing golf
rather than helping people,
it may give you a distorted way
of looking at things.
Yes, Cruz is one
of those local Never Trumpers
who's continually pushing
the false narrative
that Texas or Florida
got more recovery money
than Puerto Rico.
That's actually a lot more.
Now, Donald Trump,
when he came here...
Oh, my God,
that man is a disaster.
What? The man protects people
after a disaster.
-Not my president.
-Well-well, he sure is.
You voted for him.
I, as a Puerto Rican,
was not permitted to vote.
What is she even talking about?
Back up.
What is a Puerto Rico?
Treat me like a dumb American
who knows nothing
about Puerto Rico.
Puerto Rico is a U.S. territory,
precarious territory,
um, basically abandoned,
but, yeah, this is America.
It's like a Cuba?
Uh, definitely no.
-It's not a Cuba.
-It's like a Guam?
-Eh, probably,
-in the sense that we've been
neglected -A Florida Key?
by the U.S. government, but yes.
As long as we live
on the island,
we are not entitled to vote
for the president
or our duly elected
representatives in Congress.
Apparently, Puerto Rico
is part of the U.S.
Its people are citizens,
but they have no voting rights.
What's worse, Puerto Rico is
suffering under crippling debt,
and they are legally forbidden
to declare bankruptcy,
unlike cities
in the mainland U.S.,
where that happens
all the time.
On top of that, there's this.
The thing that Donald Trump
can do is declare the law,
the Jones Act, null.
Just scrap it.
The Jones Act is an obscure law
that says
all goods transported
between American ports
must be carried
by American ships,
which means foreign ships
coming to Puerto Rico
either pay big tariffs
or reroute to mainland U.S.,
where they transfer the cargo
to a U.S. ship.
And all those dollar signs
are paid for by the people
of Puerto Rico, making it
a fortune to rebuild.
I don't want more--
I just want equal.
All this talk of history,
feels like a lot of you guys
are just looking behind you.
From where I'm sitting,
it's beautiful.
Ten out of ten.
GONZALEZ:
Maybe. I don't know.
KLEPPER: Hmm. Okay, maybe
there was more to this recovery
than I initially thought.
I think I'm starting
to put it together. When
Donald Trump said it was a ten,
he wasn't talking
about his response.
He was talking
about the response he inspired.
See, he's always thinking
a couple of steps ahead.
So many steps,
often, he's behind.
So that I like to call
"trickle down responsibility."
People in the community, well,
then they're the ones
who step up,
they come together,
and they fix the problems,
they move forward as a people,
and thus become
that much more united.
And we all know Donald Trump--
he's a uniter.
You see it here.
Getting lost
wandering back to my hotel
because there was no GPS,
Wi-Fi or streetlights,
I came across this--
a generator-powered bar
of people finding community.
(upbeat music playing)
I saw this over and over
in my time on the island--
families filling carts
with supplies
to deliver
to hurting neighborhoods.
WOMAN:
We're survivors,
but right now,
we still need a lot of help.
KLEPPER: People adopting
long-forgotten pets.
WOMAN 2:
We need adoptions,
and we need to get planes
to ship these dogs out.
KLEPPER: Soup kitchens popping
up in closed restaurants
to help hungry people
in neighboring towns.
It's, like, you don't sit down
and wait to be fed.
You work for it.
You work hard.
There's a famous quote.
I don't know who said it.
But it's like,
"Give a man a fish,
and he will eat one day.
Help teach him how to fish,
and he will eat forever."
That was Reagan.
Smart guy.
The people, the politicians,
the cooks, the animal rescuers,
the kids, that guy--
I think I met him earlier--
they are the ten out of ten
that Trump was talking about.
It seems like a lot of people
doing small things was making
a big difference.
It made me think a lot
about myself.
I'm wondering if I could do
something, like,
the bare minimum.
Great reporting, Jordan. Great.
(cheers and applause)
Hey there. Hey,
Mr. Commander-in-Chief,
this message is for you.
Your heroic near-efforts
have inspired so many people
in Puerto Rico to step up
and take actions for themselves.
And for that,
you deserve a big thank you.
So we brought you back a gift
from the island
to show our gratitude.
-This is Izzy...
-AUDIENCE MEMBERS: Aw.
...one of the many abandoned
animals we saw down there.
-(applause and cheering) -Izzy's
such a good girl, or boy.
I don't know. I wasn't allowed
to have pets when I was a kid.
And Izzy is ready to be the
official first dog of America.
You see, you're the first
president in 150 years
to not have a pet
at The White House.
Now, some lefties
are using this against you,
saying it's evidence of your
lack of kindness and empathy,
and that you'd never be able
to take care of something
-that doesn't immediately
benefit you. -(laughter)
By adopting Izzy,
you can prove them all wrong.
And who knows?
A good photo op
with your new furry friend
could get
your approval rating back
-in the low forties
where it belongs. -(laughter)
-Yeah!
-(applause and cheering)
And Izzy... Izzy is so excited
to come live with you.
Aren't you, girl?
Or boy?
She's such a good girl or boy.
So, come pick Izzy up.
Our only request is that,
when you do,
you'll tell us about your plans
for the island.
We'll take care of, uh, her
or him here at The Opposition
until you're able to stop by.
But it's not just Trump.
Everyone can take a little step
to help Puerto Rico recover.
Here are a few
of the many sources
where you can get
more information on how
to support ongoing
relief efforts in Puerto Rico.
-The Opposition will return.
-(cheers and applause)